I want to start this week off by abiding
by one of the rules that I set up when
we launched this operation.
I said that if you guys fact check me,
I would address it on the show.
I did actually make a minor error last
week,
believe it or not,
while talking to my guest marginalized.
I mistakenly said that Ben Carson was a
neuroscientist when in fact he's a
neurosurgeon.
A that was really just a slip of the
tongue,
but a couple of you called me out on it,
so I wanted to correct myself.
Of course,
at the end of the day,
whether he's a neuroscientist or a
neurosurgeon,
one thing I hope he will not become
president of the United States.
We've got a really great response to our
interview with Magii last week.
Actually,
when we finished,
I felt like,
again,
we had been part of an important
conversation that needs to be had more.
This of course is the irony of the
regressives that bash people like Majid
and Sam Harris here,
you have two people from very different
walks of life trying to promote secular
values and coexistence.
Whether you agree with them or not,
on every point is totally irrelevant.
It should be obvious to anyone with half
a brain that these are the guys trying
to find a peaceful way forward.
Don't take my word for it.
They'll listen to them speak themselves
and by the way,
you can disagree with them on where they
stand on certain issues,
yet acknowledged that they're having a
very difficult dialogue,
unexplainably,
heated topics that most people are
completely afraid to have in the first
place.
When a journalist called modular porch
monkey and Sam a racist,
it exposes who the real extremists are
in case you missed it on Friday nights
realtime.
Bill Maher had an excellent sit down
with Richard Dawkins on this new split
on the left.
I was thrilled to hear Bill Maher
actually use the phrase regressive
leftist bill credited Sam Harris for
coining the phrase though,
from what I understand,
Majid was using it as far back as 2012.
In any event,
the fact that it trickled up to bill
shows you that the discussions we're
having here on the show as well as the
ones that you guys are having on twitter
and youtube are actually making a
difference.
That's the beauty of the Internet.
You can get issues to actually bubble up
until mainstream takes notice.
There is evidence of the awakening that
I've been talking about all over the
place right now on twitter.
Someone asked me if by calling these
people the regressive left,
if I'm just resorting to the same type
of name calling that we accuse them of
my answer to,
this is a hundred percent no.
We're giving a name to a problem we've
all seen growing for a long time.
Now we can debate with them on facts if
they accept facts as such and not just
cherry pick them when suitable for their
narrative.
The reason I feel like naming them is so
important is because I now view these
regressives as the left's version of the
tea party.
The tea party went unchecked by the
right until it was too late,
and now the Republican Party is a
fractured mess,
often only held together by its worst
beliefs.
I really believe these regressives are
doing this to the left and if we don't
have the courage to stop them,
then a year or two from now will wonder
why our system is even screwed up more
than it is now.
That's why talking about all this stuff
is important and that's why we're going
to continue to do so.
With that out of the way,
it's time to sit down with the outspoken
Breitbart,
conservative Milo Yiannopoulos and fear
not.
I won't let any of his sif like logic
screw with my thinking.
My guest this week is a writer for
Breitbart Dot Com and a general rabble
rouser and renaissance men,
Milo Yiannopoulos.
Welcome to the show.
Thanks so much for having me.
So when I tweeted out originally that
you were coming in,
half the people told me I was going to
absolutely hate you.
Half the people told me I was gonna.
Love you for wrong.
They're the first half or wrong.
Yeah.
All right,
so uh,
so we actually had a drink the other
night.
We want to be totally transparent here.
We had a drink the other night and we
talked a little bit.
So we've gotten to know each other
however much you can in an hour.
You are a gay conservative now.
I want to repeat that just so that the
audience can be clear.
You are a gay,
you think you need to repeat anything?
It's weird.
Conservative people.
People will be strange.
Well,
people freak out.
So let's just start.
Let's just start.
What is a conservative to you in 2015?
Because I think people don't even know
what sort of basic terms anymore,
much less the gay part,
but let's just.
What is a concern?
I think the reason people surprised
about a gay conservative is because we
have a slightly outdated notion of what
conservatism is now in the religious
right in America doesn't have the same
purchase on the public imagination
anymore that it wants did.
So it's a sort of part of the ripe but
not hold of it.
And the rice in Europe is drifting quite
quickly to the left.
So conservatism as a movement,
as political philosophy is a bit lost at
the moment.
One thing we can say for sure is that
people on both sides of the political
spectrum are moving toward a sort of
center right libertarianism,
and for me the big gap between people,
the big sort of defining political,
a schism,
particularly on the Internet,
but I think if everybody really is not
left and right anymore,
it's becoming between authoritarians and
Libertarians.
The issue for the left being that there
isn't much space for Libertarians,
they're conservatives who don't know,
honestly very religious or find their
own party drifting to the left are
beginning to call themselves
conservative or began to call themselves
libertarians or conservator Darien.
So I think it's an interesting
distinction to talk speak in terms of
personal liberty and freedom now.
And when you understand it like that,
it makes much more sense why a gay
person would be one.
Right?
So the part that we sort of fall out on
the,
on the same spot is the authoritarian
and libertarian part of this.
Right?
Because we don't like the
authoritarians.
I think both of us are sort of
libertarians,
libertarians are thought more of in the
conservative space,
but if you were to give me like a three
sentence synopsis of when you say to
someone,
I'm a conservative,
what are you,
what are the principles there?
What,
what are,
what is the basic bullet principles?
I think you believe in individual
personal responsibility.
You believe in freedom of thought,
of expression,
of creativity.
You believe in free markets.
You believe that the relationship,
the individual in the state should be
circumscribed quite clearly and quite
crisply.
So you believe that state has a limited
and quite well defined set of
responsibilities beyond which it should
not stretch.
Um,
you believe in the power and value of
institutional authority and community
structures.
So you believe that even if you may,
for example,
believe that even if you're not a
Christian,
you still recognize that the church has
something to offer that is a valuable
institution that keeps up kids that
we'll get to that.
But likewise,
institutions like monarchy,
you respect them because you understand
that even though,
for example,
it would be very difficult to defend the
monarchy in purely logistical.
Oh,
purely a logical terms these days.
Nonetheless,
it works best in Britain.
It is the best system yet devised and it
works brilliantly.
Impression,
even if you,
if you were to design a state today,
you wouldn't come up with it and
consider a lot of the commenters.
Are we on the wrong,
obviously wrong.
Conservatives instinctively understand
that the value of tradition and
authority and um,
and of course levels wants to tear all
those things down.
So I think those are some of the things
that people mean when they describe
themselves as conservative.
Right?
So the reason I think it's,
it's sort of a confusing term or that
all our terms have become confusing,
I think is because a lot of times now,
as you sort of alluded to in America,
we think of conservatives somehow as an
attachment to the religious right,
which is weakening a little bit,
which I think is good.
And you're saying in in England it's a
little more of a respect for the
monarchy.
Monarchy has respect for traditions,
but I think a lot of people would say,
well,
you're just in it for the man,
right?
Well,
I think it's preposterous.
And if you look at the,
look at how many working class
conservative voters there are,
why would all of these people be voting
against their own interests if that were
true?
And if conservatism are really about
protecting rich people,
why would millions of of people who
struggle to make rent or struggle to put
their kids through college or struggle
even perhaps to,
you know,
to feed their families,
vote conservative.
They do it because they appreciate the
value of,
of some of the structures around that
they love and they do it because they,
they believe in a certain limited the
state's power.
They believe in other things that go
with conservatism.
You why would so many people vote
against their interest and it's just
absurd characterization of childish
characterization of conservatism to
suggest that it is in some way just
assist them to protect them and protect
the Richard protect corporations.
I think we can all agree that
corporatism and I'm mature late
capitalism,
which existence of intricate symbiosis
with the private sector and in some
cases quite poisonous in that respect,
the bailout of the banks in the UK,
the sorts of corporate cronyism it
happens in America.
Plenty of it here too,
right?
If course.
I think we all agree that's a bad thing,
but it is by no means restricted to one
side of the political spectrum.
Yeah.
Well,
I always say there's a reason that at
least in America,
you know,
the one percent give basically 51
percent of the Republicans and 49
percent to the Democrats because
they're,
they're hedging their bets.
So yeah,
I don't believe it goes down to either
already know.
And I,
you know,
if,
if you,
if you take the view that conservatism
is about,
you know,
uh,
sticking out for the man,
you have to explain things like why
conservatives give more money to
charity,
why even conservatives who aren't
religious give more charity.
There are lots of very difficult
questions you have to answer.
If you want to make that argument for
me,
it doesn't hold water.
All right,
well that's,
that's sort of where I wanted to jump
off from and just get a basic,
a basic set of rules that were sort of
talking about here and I think we,
I think we sorted it not remotely the
most interesting thing about it.
Yeah.
All right.
Well now we're going to get into some of
the interesting stuff.
So first thing I want to ask you about
is,
I think I found out about you originally
because of Gamer Gate that I've done one
video on gate.
It was about a year ago and so basically
I said to the audience,
I said,
guys,
look,
I don't really understand this thing.
I don't know what's going on here.
I have a sense it has to do with some
people that were upset at some of the
publications and then all this doxing
and all and massage and yoga.
But I,
this is,
I don't know,
so I don't know that I can address it.
Now you're in the thick of this thing.
So I thought if we do one thing I gained
very,
can we do like a five minute really hash
it out?
Honest
what Gamergate was really about five
minutes for you.
We're all used to seeing these social
justice warriors to police language.
You say that
we're going to do plenty on that.
Very random things or sexist or racist
or misogynist or whatever.
I think we're all used to.
Now I'm the press in some cases,
reporting on things extraordinarily
badly now.
Gamergate has been a huge controversy
with people who care about these things
because both of those things have come
together.
It is a consumer movement that rejects
sloppy standards in,
in reporting about video games and video
games by the way,
are very important part of the
entertainment industry.
They're bigger than Hollywood now.
It's 97,
90,
probably about by now $90,000,000,000
industry rejects sloppy reporting about
that and all sorts of horrible
infractions of journalistic ethics and
conflicts of interest.
Almost it.
Wait,
just to stay on that though for a
second.
So basically the game companies were
sort of paying the writers to give them
better reviews.
Is that
things like that going on if 10 people
sleeping with people and writing things
about them a bit too closely,
they shouldn't have.
Basically.
It's a very fast growing industry,
so the presses nascent,
the presses grown up very fast and what
was previously a trade press,
you know,
like you know,
tree cutters weekly or the stamp
collectors monthly or whatever has
suddenly become a consumer press and it
hasn't necessarily improved it standards
commensurate with that.
The second half of it is the social
justice warriors who mentioned briefly.
There is a sort of insurgent move in
video games from a couple of wacky left
wing feminists and these are sort of far
left Israel hating Socialist Weirdos.
I'm fall a feminist to say that every,
every video game is problematic.
That there is something wrong with all
these video games and if for some reason
the journalists have sucked all this up
and have bought it all in a digit,
the same journalists who protected video
games when the religious right in the 19
eighties and nineties said that video
games turn kids into killers and
violent,
which there is no evidence of right.
We have one more slide.
None whatsoever.
Yeah.
Those same journalists nonetheless have
rolled over and accepted the feminist
critique of video games and said,
oh,
well,
video games got me get violent,
but they can make you sexist now.
Again,
there is no evidence whatsoever.
That's the case.
The research is the most generous you
could be is to say the research is that
the jury is out,
but most of the most,
most of the most credible research.
There's.
There's nothing
to be real clear on that.
So that would be like for example,
in a game like grand theft auto where
you can literally grab a woman out of
her car hunter,
but you can do that to a man too,
so you would.
You would argue that that that's not
what the anti woman because they're
there.
It's a festival.
It's imaginary.
It's not real.
And second of all,
yeah,
it's on his computer
screen and second of all,
what much of the evidence shows actually
is that people who get stuff out of
their system and it's mainly boys who
get the stuff out of their system
playing video games on nicer to people
in the real world because it's that sort
of boyish testosterone thing.
I mean,
even as homosexual is we have some
understanding of that male need to sort
of win and crushed and you know,
and do that kind of,
well,
you know,
you probably play sports.
I don't,
but you know,
I,
I take that out horizontally.
But there is,
there is that sort of male need to get,
you know,
get that sort of testosterone energy out
for system.
Uh,
and when boys do that in video games,
much of the evidence shows that they
behave nicer and rural life.
Now some have some studies say that
video games can make you hyper
competitive.
So the FIFA Games,
the football games can leave somebody a
bit more competitive,
can raise testosterone levels.
But that's a very temporary effect.
There's absolutely no evidence
whatsoever.
The video games can make is sexist and
these sorts of Cherry picked insane
feminists.
I mean just just,
just the most barmy bunkers,
all of the.
We'll get onto feminism later,
but it's coming.
If you imagine the most wacky,
stereotypical blue haired,
overweight,
furious,
you know,
fact free,
terrible lesbian.
I'm a lesbian and a feminist whether or
lesbians.
Now I'm lesbian,
feminist kind of lunatic.
That's the sort of person that's
criticizing video games.
And very often the people don't even
play video games.
This is,
this is another chapter in the culture
wars which were used to from the movies
and from books.
And so the gate know game.
Ordinary gamers have put up for 10 years
or more with their own press calling
them man babies and misogynists beating
up on them basically because it's the
trendy thing to do because these days,
progressivism and um,
you know,
sort of hating on men that kill all
white men,
kind of these feminists hashtags are
socially acceptable.
I mean,
you,
there is no,
you will get no social censure from your
peers as far as a member of the media
today for tweeting one of those
hashtags.
Now,
obviously if you did it the other way
around,
it would be a problem.
Um,
that's become fashionable.
It's become trendy for White,
sort of white guilt,
right?
White middle class girls become
fashionable for these people to beat up
on themselves,
prostrate themselves before the altar of
womanhood and say that everything that
they are and everything that they do is
terrible.
I'm so sorry.
You know,
mother guy,
or how can I make it up to you?
Um,
the reality is that actually these video
games quite good for people.
That's the crux of it.
Then it's,
it's these people,
it's the gaming community that
that is a risk that has risen up because
it's,
it is tired of being lied about and
slandered by its own press press.
The did a really good job of defending
it when the violence stuff is going on.
Jack Thompson in the nineties were
saying,
but again,
it can make you violent.
The press did a really good job of
rebutting him because he was
conservative,
but when,
uh,
a liberal and progressive critic comes
along,
they fall over themselves to agree and
start hating on their own audience.
Right.
And that's really interesting.
And it goes to really what,
90 percent of what we're going to talk
to talk about Isabelle,
because right.
I remember when Joe Lieberman,
who's,
you know,
was on the right at that time,
I guess he's an independent now when he
was railing against violence in video
games with mortal Kombat.
I remember it was very cool to say what,
what loser he was
and so added touch and.
Well,
the problem with some,
the problem with video games from the
gamers is they have no social capital.
Everybody hates them.
The right hates video games because it
says they call a school shootings and
because they're violent and a bit and
deviant and Dorky,
and you've got the sort of from the
religious right that complains that
they,
you know,
can introduce dangerous,
uh,
you know,
thoughts of,
into people's minds,
to nobody was killing anybody in the
name of God before video games.
Right.
I've never happened.
We can talk about that.
I,
Oh,
a,
some sort of thing.
Atheist,
serial killers will get up there.
Isn't,
you know,
be we're doing this in the nineties.
Right.
And the game's press did a great job of
defending,
defending video games against those
charges.
They've done a much less job,
a good job.
In fact,
they've done no job at all of defending
it against feminists who are just as
wacky and just as crazy as the old
religious right.
And in fact,
the feminists say all the same things.
They hate the same things they hate.
Nudity and violence are all the same
stuff.
This is why some very clever Brendan
O'Neill,
who is a wonderful economist and Britain
wrote in the spectator.
A great thing about it was a
provocation,
but it was,
it was interesting about how feminism
looks quite like Islam.
Islam in some regards there because it
hits the same thing it hits female
nudity to and it asks for the same staff
and it has,
uses the same language I wrote,
I did a silly quiz online in my column
about,
you know,
Anita Sarkeesian and was the leading
feminist critic of video games or Jack
Thompson who was the nineties.
We'll just write guy and I just sort of
a lined up a lot of quotes from each of
them and asked to go in here to pick
which you,
who said it and then,
but never got more than five out of 10,
uh,
which,
which is my point,
you know,
they say the same thing,
same language and it goes to that.
That difference is not really about left
and right.
It's not worry about politics anymore.
The most important political distinction
in people since more of our,
as more of our lives move online,
more of our discourses online as more
people navigate the Internet.
What the Internet has done to politics
is very interesting,
is turned every major culture,
war and every major discussion into,
around between authoritarians want to
control how other people live,
and Libertarians who either want to
escape into fantasy worlds because they
want to escape,
you know,
was going on in their life or simply
classical liberals like me who believe
in freedom of expression,
freedom of thought,
liberty of,
of idea,
and,
and believe that it is essential for the
good of our species if you like it,
if you want to get serious about it,
that we can talk about everything openly
and honestly and that there are no,
no go areas.
I'm more what my colleague at Breitbart
Alim Bukhari Cause,
uh,
a cultural libertarian.
I'm not a libertarian politically
speaking,
but I believe that in culture there
should be no boundaries and that we
should be able to explore everything.
Um,
video games are sailed on all sides from
the left,
from the right,
from everybody,
by people who want to restrict the
acceptable limits of a creative
expression.
I think that's dangerous.
I think it's dangerous wherever it
happens.
I think video games are the most
interesting entertainment medium in
which it's happening now because it is
the because gamers are the first people
who rose up and said no to the social
justice warriors and it was a horrible
and humiliating defeat for them.
Right.
So it's actually interesting.
And then we'll move on to feminism
specifically,
but it's really interesting because this
is sort
of the awakening that I now see
happening in our political discussion.
People are now hitting on this
libertarian thing and fighting the
authorities,
but it's.
But it's still relate.
The machine is
Saunas.
It's trump,
it's farrage and Corbin in the UK.
All of the populist political movements
on the left and the right,
they come from all over the counter
counter cultural antiestablishment
libertarian leanings.
Right now Corbin in the UK is much more
of a socialist as much more of a of a of
a prescriptive kind of guy,
but his supporters,
you know,
want to be able to behave terribly and
they do behave terribly.
Just this week there was spitting on
people in the to the Tory conference in
Manchester.
They want the right not just to think
terrible things like I'd microbes to
cultural image and they want to be the
right to behave abominably.
All of this stuff,
you know,
is,
is it comes from the thing I think
something we've all known for 10,
20 years.
It's increasing dissatisfaction,
alienation from the political and media
relates that the lot of ordinary voters
feel ordinary people.
I think pretty much everybody feels that
regardless of what they do and even,
and I think we'll get onto this later,
even those of us who work in the media
and have quite nice lives and come from
Nice homes and you know,
and don't really have much to complain
about.
Still feel that quite acutely and you
and I think are examples of people who
are a bit more alive to that.
A bit more aware of the fact that you
know,
that political discourse and cultural
discussion on television has become
really,
really dull.
And you've had people on your show
already and the first thing,
right?
And you've had people in the old show
and the first three episodes who are
very insistent about free speech and
free expression and the importance of,
of old victorian style,
classical liberalism,
but also the importance of mischief and
joy and a little bit of fun like
marginal,
Eh,
marginal monster you had on.
Sure it was a great lover of fun and
mischief and loves to tease people who
want to lecture him and bullied him.
And in the leftists who say to him that
he's not a proper Muslim or whatever,
you know,
because he doesn't want to pick women in
Burkas or whatever it is.
Or what is this?
To me it seems racist if you say,
well,
he's not being good enough.
Alright.
Racism.
But you see,
we started with Gamergate.
We did.
We see where we ended here.
This is what they hit us.
And I'll tell you why.
Then bring it home.
Typically the reasons.
Yeah,
it
does this,
this Gamergate is,
is the sort of final,
um,
it's almost like the final chapter in
two decades worth of Internet wars.
And those Internet wars have been about
thought speech,
culture,
politics.
You name it,
every community on the Internet and
every sub community within those sites,
which for channel Reddit,
whatever has a dog in the fight and
Gamergate because they all either have a
vested interest in free speech and
anonymity or they have an interest in
protecting the integrity,
integrity,
and creative expression of certain
attainment mediums or their,
um,
their individual people who have behaved
terribly on the Internet,
who saw Gamer Gate is a redemptive
opportunity.
So if they lined up with the,
you know,
the women and went in with these mostly
fake frets about death and rape and all
the rest of it.
Um,
it typical leftist feminist tactics that
don't stack up when you look into them
move,
she will get into,
I'm going to challenge me.
A lining up on one side of that debate
was a way of indicating whether you were
for Authoritarians or libertarians.
And it was a sort of confluence of all
of these arguments and wars online and,
and,
and it takes you in these crazy
directions because in a way it's sort of
the most all encompassing a war and the
most all encompassing event that's ever
happened on the internet because it
brought in everybody,
all of the old battles,
you know,
something people don't realize is when
you range up the sides on Gamer Gate,
there are people who were involved in
was five years ago.
You kind of take picking the same sorts
of sides.
This is a,
this is the best example we have yet
most exciting example.
Culturally we haven't journalists.
There's on such a terrible idea,
terrible job of reporting on this
concentrated these fake rape threats.
Conservatives or miss the miss,
the huge cultural opportunity here.
I'm shamefully so leftists have not even
bothered to make the arguments because
they know their arguments in nonsense
and they focused on the threats.
This was such an interesting example of
what I was saying earlier,
the fact that on the Internet that it's
not about left and right anymore.
It's about authoritarians and
Libertarians and cultural libertarians
are the rising power,
and they're the people who love me.
They're the people met.
I think much of your audience falls into
the same bucket.
Actually,
the people who love Lauren Southern,
the libertarian candidate,
Canadian politician,
they love Cathy Young,
a great veteran journalist of Christina
Hoff summers at the American Enterprise
Institute.
Adam Baldwin,
the actor,
but all of the,
even Eli Roth,
a director is making a movie about
social justice,
where right now,
you know,
um,
cultural libertarianism is on the rise
because people are sick of political
correctness.
People are sick of being told they're
racist,
sexist,
misogynist,
transphobic when they know they're not.
Once again,
I think by asking you about Gabriel,
we just hit on a zillion.
We hit on a zillion.
It's a huge topic.
That is the best I can do.
All right,
so we're going to leave it there and I'm
sure the commenters are going to have a
field day with it,
which is great.
So let,
let's talk about some other stuff.
So feminism,
which you've already enlightened me a
bit on,
you really,
really are against feminism.
And before I let you do your piece,
now my sense is that feminism,
at least the way it started,
was that women wanted equality.
They wanted the same equality of
opportunity that men had.
There is no doubt that,
uh,
most of these roads in our society have
been easier for men.
I think you would argue that that's
changed now.
But so what,
what do you think of the feminist
movement?
You were just kicked out of the Amber
Rose sidewalk,
uh,
two days ago.
He was in your situation with you today.
We didn't run into him because he's
given her a piece of my mind.
Why would you hate feminists?
Well,
the picture you painted perfectly
accurate,
or at least it was until perhaps 10,
maybe 15 years ago.
Certainly recently.
It's changed very recently.
I think most people instinctively agree
with the equality of opportunity.
And of course you have access for women.
They want women to have the opportunity
to do anything.
They want to rise as high as a man,
if they're prepared to work as hard and
put the same amount of hours in.
And of course I agree with that.
I think everybody agrees with that.
That's not what modern intersectional
third wave as it's called feminism is
about,
which seems to me and I think to a lot
of women,
to primarily to be about man hating.
It is a very angry,
bitter.
I'm a profane.
I'm lesbian of feminism.
No,
like right to be angry though.
I mean as the other
dinner,
an oppressed class.
Well that women don't make equal money
as men or is that a myth about this all
the time,
but of course it's a myth.
It's one of those feminists missed that
won't die.
Basically.
If you take all of the earnings of men
and all of the earnings of women and you
do a simple bit of maths,
then you'll get something like a 77.
What?
This doesn't take into account as the
different choices that women make.
It doesn't take into account a variety
of factors.
No reputable economists takes the wage
gap seriously,
but it's repeated because,
um,
you know,
I mean we still,
we saw where the stuff comes from just
this week for slut walk.
I was kicked out of.
I'm a journalist for Time magazine
reported that 50,000
people that come out in support of the
slut walk,
I was there.
It was like maybe 250.
She blathered she,
you know,
started to sort of blame other people
and eventually they changed it to
thousands,
but it was still wrong.
This sort of like sloppy ideological
reporting.
And I'm sorry to say that the most
brazen untruths always come from the
left.
Just like most of the major plagiarism
scandals come from the left because they
believe in narrative over fact.
This is how rollingstone happened.
Um,
you know,
the,
the fake rape in rolling stone,
it's our Duke Lacrosse happens.
It's how,
you know,
all of these things happen because these
liberal journalists believe that even if
this one's not true,
it's really important for us to talk
about.
So I'm with you on that because even
with some of my prior guests like Sam
and budget,
this is what they've done is what they
experience,
you know,
and they're getting the receiving end of
it.
Um,
you know,
the,
these,
these memes of like,
you know,
there's foot,
whether it's three,
four or five women,
one in three,
one in four,
one in five women are going to get
sexually assaulted on campus,
which is just nonsense.
Whether it's the wage gap,
which is nonsense,
you know,
these things become established as part
of almost almost.
They won't become almost folkloric and
look right up to the president.
I mean Obama repeat some of these
statistics,
but they're not true.
And if you look at the work,
for example,
Christina Hoff summers I mentioned
earlier,
the American Enterprise Institute who to
very crisply and cleanly and
entertainingly debunks this stuff I'm
working on getting well,
she's great and you should,
I mean she's,
she takes a scalpel to these guys and
it's,
it's clinical and brilliant to watch it.
None of this stuff stacks up.
So if you're trying to make the case
that women have a right to be angry,
that they should be angry because women
have all of these injustices will ask
you what are these injustices?
And every single one that's given by
feminist,
every example,
it's giving me a feminist does not stand
up to scrutiny.
Women are not an oppressed class in the
west.
There is no rape culture in the West.
We don't celebrate rapists.
We put them in prison.
Women don't earn less than men for the
same work.
That's illegal.
It is true that you know,
because women are mothers.
There are consequences when it,
when you get into the workplace on that.
But a woman is paid the same work as a
man.
So when you,
when you,
when you say there's a way this
confusion between wages and earnings,
you know,
when you say seventy cents to the
dollar,
what women here is,
well,
I'm going to get page seventy seven
cents for a man's pound.
No woman has that experience.
It doesn't happen.
You know,
there's some women who work part time
because they have children.
Well,
they have children.
What do you expect?
You know,
the important thing is that we make sure
that when women come back to work after
they have children,
that they're not disadvantaged for that.
Now where that's happening,
that's wrong.
But it is not,
it is not a problem on the scale of
what,
uh,
you know,
Sam Harris and Majid we'll talk about,
happening to women in the Middle East
and feminists will never talk to you
about this difficult stuff because they
don't want to be,
they don't want to be put in a difficult
position of having to rank Islam versus
women.
Right?
So that,
that's where I'm western Western world.
It's a western union,
western world western feminism
complaining about manspreading
mansplaining,
this constant,
this constant message that men are evil
and broken and wrong,
toxic masculinity.
This is offensive.
It's irritating,
it is wrong.
And it's district.
All right,
so let's,
let's go right to that.
Um,
you wrote a piece this week about this,
about the shooter in Oregon,
and your,
your piece basically was saying that men
are being abused in the media or so are
so easily dismissed in society,
uh,
that,
that they're acting out in crazy ways.
And we have to stop treating men like I
know.
And I know a lot of people on the left
for a lot of the reasons you're
describing will read something like that
and say,
you know,
this is nonsense men.
Men have all the power.
Yeah.
I mean what I said was that it at least
part of the reason that some of these
young men are acting out that we have
these shootings,
these shootings happening at least some
of the reason for that is the horrible
position we've put men in.
Now you can read everyday and major new
media publications,
um,
that,
there is a,
there is a problem intrinsically with
being a straight white male or just
being a white man,
um,
that somehow that gives you privileged
access to certain institutions that you
are somehow problematic.
That's not the experience of young men
today who go through university.
And our one in seven of them is,
it were put on Ritalin or adderall
because they are held up to a female.
But a female behavior standards.
It's not the experience of boys.
There's a direct connection between the
medication and the and this.
Well,
of course there is,
of course,
of course there is a behavior not be
upstanders babies standards.
Of course there is because behavior has
done,
I'm,
I,
I meant behavior,
behavior standards.
Um,
and we're not just doing that,
but we're also changing the way the
exams are mark,
to make them easier for women because
women don't test well and exams.
So boys are struggling,
boys are falling behind.
And this is not a controversial thing.
Everybody knows this boy's are falling
horribly behind girls in education.
Fewer men are going to the university,
more women graduate when we get higher
grades in the workplace.
For example,
Cornell study from 2015 showed that
women who have a two to one advantage
going for the same job just because
everybody's desperate to hire women.
The experiences of men growing up now do
not reflect these horrible headlines,
um,
about straight white men.
And frankly,
I think progressives have got themselves
into a really weird corner.
They don't seem to appreciate the irony
of criticizing somebody for their skin
color and their orientation,
but they do it anyway,
right?
And they would say,
well,
this is the group that's in power.
So if they're being well,
they would say yes,
the only claim that there is a sort of
mystical force in society known as the
patriarchy.
And what these feminists will claim is
that the patriarchy is responsible for
keeping women down and all of these
crazy expressions like toxic message in
whatever flow from this,
this tired old ideology,
um,
about male power and an overseas.
Now,
as Camille Paleo,
that wonderful dissident feminist critic
says,
you know,
if society but left in the left in the
hands of women,
we'd still be living in mud huts.
Thank God for the Patriarchy Patriarchy
that got us to the moon.
It's the patriarchy to built the
Internet,
the patriarchy that built this floor and
the ceiling women didn't want to do that
is the patriarchy that drives oil trucks
in a steeple jacks.
You know,
women don't want to do that stuff
either.
We're perfectly happy to complain about
gender representation when there aren't
enough women,
when,
when there aren't enough women in a,
in a particular subject field for our
arbitrary quotas.
But we don't make it the same complaint
the other way around,
right?
But all of this stuff,
we're the ones that were going out and
hunting and women were taking care of
the home.
So I find that argument is a little
flimsy because
are there are people who say that's not
a bad way to structure society.
I mean when we start to break down those
gender.
Look,
this all comes from this sort of
credited leftest idea that gender is
socially constructed and agenda is
socially constructed,
right?
If you're taught to be a boy or taught
to be a girl,
rather than having a lot of that
behavior,
genetic behavior sort of encoded in you,
if you like,
as a virtue by virtue of your
chromosomes,
if you,
if,
if gender is a performance and it's a
social construct,
there's no reason why girls compared to
boys and boys can't behave like girls.
Now we're beginning to start to see that
fall apart.
Now,
one of the ways in which it falls apart
as the transgender debate,
we know now,
now progressives are telling us the baby
can be born with the wrong brain.
Um,
if you could be born with a female
brain,
there must be such a thing as a female
brain.
So surely femininity can't be as a copy
of social construct.
Make your bloody mine's up.
The thing that you see on this was that,
you know,
everybody was saying that Abi or most
sane people I think were saying that
obviously Rachel Dolezal couldn't choose
to be black.
She was white and she pretended
created by progressive.
So you said that blackness was a
performance that you could,
that blackness was a social construct
that race was.
Now that rat race is a social construct.
Of course it isn't,
you know,
we know now because we have the computer
processing power to do it.
We know that the,
you know,
when we look at the genome,
that there are clusters of clusters of,
of information that map onto certain
geographies in that's in that
statistical sense.
We know now that race is real.
Um,
and you know,
we know from ordinary people know from
common sense of our eyes and ears,
you know,
we know that people look different and
behave differently.
Um,
we know that stuff,
but progressives for Mr,
variety of barmy reasons,
best known to themselves have been
claiming that's gender and race are
social constructs.
All this stuff is starting to fall apart
now.
Is the gender one falling part?
I don't want to Belabor this point,
but the gentleman's fully believe that
people can be trans because I,
I know,
I know some trans people.
I have no doubt
I didn't say that.
I want to say what I said.
What I said was I'm transgender debate
is very interesting and very dangerous
for progressives and they haven't yet
dealt with this.
Um,
if you can be born with the wrong brain,
if you can be born,
if you can be born a man with a woman's
brain,
that means is such a thing as a woman's
brain.
Right?
So what,
what transgender patients will do is
they start hacking away at themselves to
make them,
you know,
and it's an anatomically more like
women.
So they're somewhere between the two
genders,
by the end of it,
right?
And they're not functioning women,
but they look a bit more like women.
Um,
and some of their,
some things work a bit more like women
and they have the appearance of women
and they say they have a woman's brain.
If you're gonna have a woman's brain.
There is such a thing as a woman's brain
is there's a biological basis for
certain behavioral differences.
Now you were asking me about sort of men
going out to forage may not maybe no bad
thing that we let men be career,
you know,
be the hunter gatherers and women may
indeed be happier focusing on bringing
up,
bringing up children and building a
home.
Certainly the women that I know that are
in their twenties that have been told,
especially in their thirties,
have been told they can have it all.
They can have a career.
They're living in a horrible apartment.
They don't live with a cat.
They're miserable or hay or their
friends.
They're not happy people.
They've been encouraged to be single,
encouraged by feminism particularly to
look how they want it.
So this,
this fat,
but fat positivity.
That is another feminist trope is that
you can look like what you want their
self esteem shouldn't depend on what a
man thinks of you.
Well,
yes,
it should because if you want to,
you know,
if you want to settle down with a
manual,
like,
and have a nice happy life.
There are certain things that men liking
women like stay thin.
Um,
you know,
and you may not like it,
but it's a fact.
As gay men,
we know that men are visual animals
right now.
Some,
some guys like fat girls,
but not many.
Um,
and if,
if you,
if you're listening to feminists who
were telling you can grow blue armpit
hair and you can burp and Fart and
swear,
you can be Lena Dunham,
this disgusting,
quivering,
massive horror.
Um,
you know,
and men will like you.
That's a lie,
will not like you and you'll be alone
and you'll be miserable.
I know a lot of people here are going to
say,
well,
this is sort of somehow this is some of
your gay rage or misogyny coming out in
some of this stuff.
So let's say I don't have a dog in the
fight,
I don't care.
I don't care if you're thin or fat as a
woman,
I don't want to fuck you either way.
I don't care what I want is for people
to be happy and I see people not being
happy because I see that women are
moving in a very,
very dangerous direction.
Told lies by Wacky fall f feminist
crazies who want to control other people
because they're hurting inside.
I think in many cases very often it's
30,
40 year old bitter old woman trying to
lecture 20 year old girls on how to
behave.
It's an ugly woman on woman form of
violence if you like a modern feminism.
It is a nasty thing to watch.
And I see women get drawn into this and
I find it sad.
But there is of course one great hope
and,
and a silver lining to all this,
which is that,
um,
feminism is collapsing in popularity
among women.
Um,
in just a few years.
The number of American women who
described themselves as feminist has
gone from 28 to 18 percent.
You can read in Vox is not somewhere
that would advertise.
This may just be because of the success
of the movement.
Women who don't identify as feminists
and they don't identify as feminists
because they see in feminism or IC,
which is turned into a bitter,
nasty,
ugly man hating empty horror show and
frankly you read these blogs like
Jenzabar,
which you know which a rail against men.
Most women don't hate men.
Most women don't want to beat up on
people for being straight or being white
or being a male.
Most people quite like a boyfriend,
you know,
so they see it.
They don't have anything in common with
these angry gender warriors who want to
deny basic human nature and who make
claims and give instructions that are
almost designed to make women miserable.
And I think most women recognize that,
which is why feminism is falling off a
cliff with women.
I love how you wrap up.
Even the things I disagree with in the,
in the social justice warrior prism,
because that's my.
That's my weak spot because I'm so
against that that I have to sort of
acknowledge some of what you're saying
here.
Um,
all right.
So let's,
let's do one more thing and then I,
and then I want to spend the whole
second half of this really on,
on one topic specifically,
and I want to talk about atheism because
it's been one of the so boring.
All right?
So just a couple of people wrong in a
room being very angry on the Internet.
So you don't,
you,
I sense,
you almost think that atheists don't
exist,
that there's some lesbians don't exist.
They're already.
Unfortunately there are.
They're going to force you.
There are.
So there are a,
you acknowledged that there are lots of
wrong people in the world,
you know,
and one of the wrong kinds of wrong
people are atheists.
Now the thing I find fun about it,
I didn't really care if somebody
believes in God and I hope they do.
I wish they did because I know it'd be
quite nice if they join me up there in
40 slash 50 years,
but there's something up there.
I've got a first class ticket.
She loves me.
I'm very confident.
There's nothing up there.
There's a lighting grid have been built
by men.
Uh,
no,
but I mean,
the reason I.
The reason I haven't go atheists because
it's fun because they're so thin skin.
They're like,
come.
They're like libertarians or they're
like cyclists or Liberal Democrats in
the UK or you know,
any other sort of feminists.
In fact,
they're so easy to wind up.
I mean,
you know how many atheists it takes to
change a light bulb and before you've
even given the punchline,
people are furious and there's a reddit
thread about it and they're just so much
fun.
I understand.
But why will you be going after the
people that it's easy to go after?
I mean,
every poll shows that the most hated
my in the country.
People would know these victims.
These,
these people have some of the most
celebrated public intellectuals on their
side.
Richard Dawkins,
the late Christopher Christopher
hitchens.
These people have huge public
intellectuals on their side.
Millet,
militant atheism,
if you'd like.
If he is Mr trendiest thing in the
world.
Every journalist is an atheist.
Everybody in the media,
as an atheist,
you know,
you're never going to get somebody laugh
at you or look at you weirdly for
announcing you're an atheist,
you announced you're a Christian or a
Muslim or if or maybe especially a Jew.
Um,
you know,
all sorts of bad things happen to you,
right?
Nobody,
nobody looks at you funny except me.
I'm probably one person.
If you announced that you were an
atheist,
so don't be that victim because if you
know this is,
this is the,
this is a privileged group in society
that I find it funny to take the Mickey
out of because they are so touchy.
This is interesting because.
So when you were talking about
Gamergate,
part of what you liked is that there was
this groundswell coming up from the
bottom,
fighting this authoritarian sense.
I think religion people have that again
now,
but I don't think we're there yet.
I,
I get that angle and this is what all my
friends on the say,
that
the bridge is now are the ones being
oppressed and Christians are being.
I wouldn't go so far as to say
oppressed,
but saying it's basically crazy as is
wrong.
I wouldn't go as far as to say
Christians are an oppressed class in
this country because I don't think there
aren't many press clusters in this
country.
I can't do anything.
Know,
maybe black people still.
That's probably the only one in this
country.
Um,
I don't think they're an oppressed
class,
but I do think,
um,
I've been very ashamed of my fellow,
my fellow homosexuals in the way they
have behaved toward Christians in some
of the media circus that happened
recently.
I have so I can,
I can go with you on that.
Plead,
plead deeply,
horrifying to watch gay people treat
Christians as gays were treated for
barely two decades ago.
Sure.
So,
but I do think there's some value there,
but I do.
I have noticed I did a David Webb who's
going to be a guest on our show in a
couple weeks from Fox News and on Sirius
Xm.
I was on his show when gay marriage was,
was being passed by the Supreme Court
and the law was being struck down to
shame is shame and we'll get to that too
in a second,
but what he said to me,
it just literally,
I think it was the first day was the day
that had happened was that we should
really already start being a.
We should start policing the gaze to
make sure we don't start pressing
Christian,
but isn't that.
Don't we have to give it a little time?
Don't we have to let gays have a little
time to work with to be bullied someone
before suddenly accusing them?
No,
no,
no.
We don't need to give gay people anytime
to be bullies.
They have shown and this is a,
this is what you are.
This is something that I always find
interesting about people,
how they behave when they enter the
corridors of power,
how people behave when they are granted
the status that they have asked for for
so long when gays are finally not just
equal in society,
but held up as models of paragons of
virtue.
I mean,
you read it,
you read Gawker,
buzzfeed,
you would think they'd be engaged with
some kind of moral objective,
but being gay with someone so you know,
it was better than being straight in
some way.
Um,
you know,
I'm not gonna say,
well,
we'll,
we'll perhaps discuss it in the second
half of the show,
what I think on that,
but um,
but,
but it seems like a weird proposition
and therefore on the face of it.
But if you read buzzfeed or vox or
Corker,
you'll get that impression.
Um,
no,
I don't think gay people deserve anytime
to be bullies to settle into,
you know,
their position or authority.
And I think it does gay people a lot of
damage to see these bitter,
hysterical,
Nasty Queens bullying and lecturing and
hectoring,
ordinary decent law abiding people of
faith.
And I thought it was utterly deplorable
when that couple who staged a renew of
the vowels,
they didn't even have a wedding,
but they staged a renewal of the vows
because already had the wedding solely.
It seemed to get a photo opportunity
with pizzas from memories,
pizza,
which they they,
they tricked this Christian Christian
pizzeria into catering their thing.
Now set aside the horror,
I think most gay people will feel about
pizza and whether the carb would.
I know I'm Greek and 13 showing I've
told you a cameraman to shoot me from
here.
Set that aside,
or how hollow and bitter,
what a terror,
what an awful kind of human being you
would have to be to turn your special
day of.
Send a day of appreciation and
celebration between you and your family,
the people that you love into an a cheap
political stump.
People that you think that gay people in
many cases turn themselves into the
worst kind of grandstanding bigots.
No,
they do not need time to settle in
there.
Very much settled.
Right.
So I,
I'm sort of with you on that because I,
I do understand that.
Look this,
they purposely did this for a Christian
Baker had they went to have they go to
an orthodox Jewish Baker or,
or a Muslim baker and forced them to do
this.
The media wouldn't have nearly the fun
that they had,
but so just wrapping this around atheism
and then we're going to do everything
else we're going to do is gay for the
rest of this after,
after this final question,
I know it's exhausting learning about
what position of power do you think
that,
that I don't see atheists in any
position.
Yes.
There are a couple cool thought of
atheists out there.
Right?
So not about Neil degrasse Tyson or
talking to someone about it because it's
not about positions of power.
It's about,
well,
what do you think?
Social cache,
but.
So what do you think that the,
the main,
the average atheist,
which an atheist is only brought
together by the lack of belief in a
deity.
A what
brought together by um,
you know,
sort of whispery facial hair,
terrible spectacle,
sort of long ginger ponytails,
terrible,
thin skinned,
natural sort of demeanor to hair trigger
temper.
These are the primary characteristics of
an atheist looking at socks and sandals.
Terrible cheap Chinos,
you know,
all that kind of stuff.
That's what you want to consider.
If that's what you want to respond to,
then go right ahead.
But you know,
Catholic Catholics have all the best
outfits,
you know,
rich,
older men in dresses.
What's not to love whenever you want,
if you want everyone to have a sense of
style and you become a Muslim or
Catholic.
Um,
no,
I mean,
look,
atheists are,
it is not just acceptable,
but it is the norm in any metropolitan
city in Europe or in America to be an
atheist.
It is normal to be an atheist.
People look at you weird if you're not
right.
So what?
So what's the problem with that?
That's,
that's the part I think it's funny to
take the piss out of them.
You just want to make fun of them.
Even though I enjoy making fun.
The Mondrian,
making fun out of everybody and you're
making fun of you.
I enjoyed making fun of myself.
I make fun out of myself all day on my
twitter feed.
That's what,
that's what
provocateurs do.
All right,
well I can accept that.
I will grant you that,
but I won Niger one,
that little section,
but.
Well,
you can have one hour if you can have
that.
I want to spend the rest of the time
talking about a whole bunch of gay stuff
because I mentioned on the show a week
and we've done five of these here.
I think this is our fifth episode since
we've been with aura.
I've only watched once mentioned
anything about being gay.
I don't,
I don't make it an issue unless it's
relevant and it is what it is.
I mean,
believe me,
I'm gay.
I'm married.
You know what I mean?
I'm married to do pretty gay.
Okay.
Um,
but I,
I don't know.
I know.
Okay.
So you will selling,
selling out,
selling out to the Hetero picture
institution.
Yes.
We'll get to those.
Yeah.
I know you have a better game.
My God.
Right.
Anything more awful.
So before
we do that portion of this,
it's hilarious.
The,
the liberal here married one.
The conservative one is the one railing
against marriage.
It's,
it's fascinating.
I just think it's sad that,
you know,
I want heterosexual to come back to the
institution of marriage.
I want them to realize that it's a good
thing.
I want them to become more socially
conservative in that regard.
I don't want gay people being growing
up.
Right?
So we're just going to go all in on
this.
I'll reverse my question.
So go,
go.
Alright.
I didn't think being gay
particularly fun and I wouldn't choose
it for my children.
For example,
I think Sally Cohen who said that they'd
like so that she'd like to have a gay
child.
I thought it was deplorable and sadistic
and incredibly selfish.
So meaning what if,
if salsify has come to a place of
realization,
what she said was if she could,
if she said what she said was if she
could pick,
she'd rather have a gay kid.
And I thought that was a horrible thing
to say because what?
What's your last child?
My Trans Life.
So much more miserable.
But,
but it's getting easier every day.
We're,
don't you think that when,
uh,
how old are you?
Oh Gee.
You don't ask again.
All right,
well if you really aren't a proper gay.
Oh yeah.
Terrible failure as a gay man lady.
What point b?
It's a lot,
it's a lot easier for you than it was
for a 30 year old gay man 10 years ago
and it's going to be way shobin the
normalcy that will,
you're confusing two different things.
There's a sort of practical,
um,
ease with which a gay person can go
through life because there is no longer
the entrenched homophobia if you like it
in wider society.
The um,
the fact that gay people can,
can show,
can have a relationship and live
together and nobody really cares.
And I don't think anybody cares anymore.
Um,
well I've said that for a long time.
I'm so sick of talking about it,
which is why I don't.
All I wanted was equal rights.
I just want to be treated better than
anybody.
I think gay people
for getting married and in relationships
is a shame because I quite like the
distance.
I'm a naughty sort of aspects of gay
life and I think that it's part of my
gay privileged to be able to tumble out
of a nightclub at 3:00
AM with,
you know,
sort of dormant on my arm and he hops
off off my face.
But
Oh,
you do that while still having other
people like you,
people like you getting married,
getting a dog,
living in a little house in a horrible,
horrible,
no self respecting gay home,
enough to feed something like that.
I doesn't know what you're doing with
your time.
What do you think?
He'll come home and come and sit down
and I tell him who's cooking tonight.
Oh,
should I do?
all right then.
Well,
he's awful,
awful,
awful.
But you shouldn't be in house long
enough.
You've got to keep that alive.
But really do you really believe that?
I get it.
I get what you're doing here on the
snark level.
I get it.
No,
I do think there's some value in this
cause
I think that,
and I think it's because gape.
Look,
homosexuality is a dissident apple
sexuality.
I mean that in a,
in a morally neutral sense.
You just mean it's the other.
I don't know.
I don't mean that in using the term
correctly,
but what do you mean?
No,
I didn't say apartment.
I said,
look,
I'm,
let's,
let's set the religion stuff aside
because I was going to get into a rabbit
hole,
but let's just say you know,
what is not the norm.
It is an abhorrent sexuality that Mother
Nature May do for a variety of reasons,
right?
There's some evidence that people with
higher iqs are more likely to engage in
different sexual appetites is one of the
reasons why gay people have
disproportionately higher iqs and one of
the reasons I think,
for example,
that guests would get back in the closet
because we're making society stupider
because gay people aren't reading
anymore.
Um,
it was previously you could,
you would have a marriage with a woman
and you would have a couple of kids and
gay men were still in the gene pool
right now.
They've taken themselves out and they
don't have their own biological children
anymore.
Like you've got your sort of two to five
percent of the smartest men in
population not breeding in.
Yeah.
What people keep saying,
are we going to have kids?
And I say,
I don't know,
but we're going to keep it.
If you do,
you should have your own biological
children because you're smarter than
most people in your lab.
Did you catch that?
What we're going to keep trying.
Oh,
see,
you're so into your thing.
They're being serious.
All right.
Um,
yeah,
no.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Um,
it doesn't,
it doesn't work when,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of a silly thing,
but it's certainly true that the sort of
average intelligence society sort of
chugging up with slowly,
but it is definitely being retarded.
If a five to 10 percent of two to five
percent rather have the smartest people
in society aren't breathing anymore.
So anyway,
I think that's a silly argument.
But,
um,
I,
I do think there is,
it's a shame when,
as a gay is just one of those people
that Mother Nature has selected to be
different and to test stuff out and to
push the boundaries,
which we'll come onto in a minute.
In respect to free speech,
I think,
um,
that you sort of buy into precisely the
sort of,
uh,
sort of socially conservative
institutions,
which I love and I recognize the
building blocks of society.
I recognize at the basis of elephants,
I'm fascinated
as a homosexual,
not escapes that shouldn't have them as
a homosexual.
You should recognize that your,
your evolutionary function is to
experiment with different models of
things.
Right.
And one of the ways in which gay culture
and society has done is the sort of sex
matt hedonism that I enjoy that I think
I.
I'm sorry that you didn't,
you don't have any more because you have
this horrible.
Well I've done.
Wait,
hold on.
But you're combining different things
here.
So first off,
the sense that a lot of what you're
saying is you just,
you long for the day probably when you
were 22 and you were out every night and
doing all kinds of drugs and having all
kinds of.
All right,
so we'd last week,
right?
So you on for that day and a lot of,
a lot of mainstream gay look,
I live in West Hollywood.
I see what the.
So I think gay people have become very,
very dull,
but it's a shame isn't that?
No,
it's not good because we assess,
we have equality.
No.
Why would we want to be equal?
We were already superior.
Why would we want to go down to a
quality?
It's absurd to me.
We,
you know,
we have gay people in the world,
Mother Nature makes mistakes and make so
great discoveries.
That will be great.
[inaudible] called the gate geniuses in
history.
You know,
whether it's cheering or you know,
Abe Lincoln reportedly,
or you know,
all the,
the Roman emperors,
you know,
look at what Mother Nature does with
these special people at the top end of
the intelligence and sort of decisions a
scale.
Those,
those,
what steve jobs will called the crazy
ones,
right?
And this is why the tech and gaming
industry so disproportionately I'm gay
and Trans because it's those special
people that have brains wired slightly
differently from others who could make
those great leaps,
who can consider problems differently,
who could,
who are generally more creative and more
what I'm with you on the music
as a why as a member of the game master
race,
would you want to slump down to the
level of heterosexuality
because you should have the option.
I'm not telling you what to do if you
want the option,
what I'm telling you as you made the
wrong choice.
Okay?
So you don't think that a lot of these
people that are doing all the things
that I did them,
all of those things,
sex,
drugs,
all of that.
I did all that.
You know what I mean?
I don't.
I look back on much of it very fondly.
Actually.
People,
people call me a traitor to my
sexuality,
Tracy Tracy,
at least that moment to fill.
I think my agent would allow me to tell
you why come to,
but um,
you know,
but wouldn't you?
So the things that you,
I think you're looking at this in this
nostalgic way of fun,
but there was the sense of,
but wouldn't you trade some of that?
Look,
when you think about all the people that
are having promiscuous sex and getting
all that,
are those numbers going to directly go
down because
care about sexually transmitted
diseases.
Who gives a shit?
I don't care about that.
What I care about is the fact that this
is a serious point here.
It's not just the foreigner living those
fun lifestyles,
and I mentioned Steve Jobs earlier and
he said,
but much moment,
many of his innovations come from the
faculty took Lsd,
right?
Gay people have a license to experiment
and license to explore.
Um,
and it's one of the reasons why I'm gay
culture,
which is so,
so,
um,
to do with exploring boundaries,
pushing the limits of acceptable
discourse and speech and thought,
right?
Those are all the things that I love
that I know you don't because you slid,
slid into,
I'm honoring all the slit,
boring domesticity.
It is precisely with those,
put those horizon broadening experiences
which you have given up as a,
as a,
as a housewife or house husband or
whatever.
I think two weeks of having home cooked
meals and watching that for two weeks,
if I wanted to enjoy myself,
I want to kill myself and people call me
a traitor,
my sexuality please.
Um,
no.
Look,
I think that gay people are one of the
groups in which mother nature sort of
one of the groups,
Mother Nature's given license to go go
wild.
And that's why so many great artists and
inventors and authors and all ever been
gay,
lesbian,
whatever,
right?
Because we have a unique license and
unique opportunity in insight into the
fringes,
into the that the edge of culture that
makes stuff interesting.
We have an ability to push further than,
than ordinary people can.
We can say things they can't say.
For example,
I can go on TV and say all manner of
outrageous things about feminism only
because I'm homosexual.
Right.
Let me ask you this.
Do you think I could get away with those
same things?
Because obviously we have a little
different effect.
People always say to me,
you don't see gay,
which I know you wouldn't able to you
would you say it as compliment kind of
my thing,
right?
People know that I'm going to do this
sort of social justice proof.
It's very difficult to argue that a
flamboyant homosexual who never shuts up
about.
How about,
you know,
black boyfriends is in any way bigoted,
right?
So it gives me,
have established myself in the public
mind,
the public imagination in a way that you
haven't.
So a lot of that,
ironically,
that's what this is about you like while
you were in some ways rail against these
people that want to be protected like
the feminists or whatever you do.
Like
I enjoy using their weapons against them
and I'm perfectly open to use a weapon
against.
I wish I didn't have too much.
No,
I don't want to be trolling people for
my whole life.
Of course I don't,
you know,
but I would much rather it were the case
that everybody had free open frank
discussion.
But as the media as currently
constituted,
if you want to push forward to
discussion outside the realms of
academia in the public square talking to
ordinary people.
For example,
I write for a publication that sort of
mid Brown midmarket publication for
everyone.
The,
the sort of Digital Media Company of a
tabloid newspaper.
Um,
I wanna talk to everybody and to push
debate forward in those environments.
You do have to play by the rules and
some of those rules are based on
identity politics,
which I think are absurd and obscene.
Stupid.
But I will certainly play along with
them if it helps because it's so long as
as progressives and feminists refused to
have a debate on the base of the facts
and insist on having a debate,
you know,
the basis of identity and skin color
instead.
Fine.
I can beat them in that too.
You know,
I'm happy to beat you on any playing
field on any battlefield you choose.
They've chosen identity politics.
I can beat them there if they ever want
to come to the table and debate
properly,
I think.
I think you're onto something
interesting there that you'll use their
weapons.
I don't like their weapons.
And you're,
that you're using their weapons against
them.
I think in a cheeky sense were you were,
you know,
that you're a wink to what,
anybody who reads my twitter feed knows
it's,
you know,
I know exactly what's up.
I know what's going on,
but they still lose.
Anyway.
Um,
so,
so part of the reason why I wanted to do
this is because I do find that again,
while we come from different,
we literally come from different
countries but come from different
political parts of this that you really,
at least in American media,
only get one gay,
only one gay gets out there and it's the
bravo gay that's either on tv because
they're a Fashionista or they're a
sidekick to one of the housewives or
they're somehow involved in pop culture
or something like that.
Or every now and again someone can break
free like an Anderson Cooper,
but then sort of have to be completely
asexual,
right?
Never talk about their life.
And I think this is sort of interesting
because we both break that,
that paradigm.
Yes.
And I think it's probably because we are
cultural libertarians.
I would certainly describe myself as
one.
I think you'd probably agree with that.
I think that we are those sorts of
insurgent,
countercultural,
new media personalities.
We exist.
You may not like to hear this,
but we exist on a spectrum with people
like trump and ann coulter,
a motor.
It probably only went more on the
serious end of it simply in tapping into
ordinary people's frustrations with the
limits and absurdities of,
you know,
what they see on broadcast television
and what they read in the newspapers.
There is an alternative way of having a
discussion which is more honest and
more,
um,
more.
I mean,
this kind of thing could not happen on
broadcast television for example.
And that's a problem.
That's a problem for the media.
It's one of the reasons that,
exactly one of the reasons everybody
hates them.
Um,
you know,
and I think we both started taking
advantage of that fact as far as
sexuality goes.
What I find interesting about,
you know,
a liberal and conservative homosexual
agreeing on so much about
authoritarianism is that from my point
of view of homosexuality is where we
experiment and you know,
Drag Queen Culture for example,
is all about pushing the boundaries of
acceptable language and thought we see
the threats to freedom of speech.
For example,
we see the authoritarian threat of
coming over the horizon a long time
before anybody else and we're in a
position to warn other people about it.
Um,
and as a very serious point about this,
which is not just that,
you know,
transsexuals to hate drag queens,
which is one front in this sort of
progressive fracturing because drag
queens loves,
you know,
there's sort of no holds bar Joan River
style comedy,
which you know,
is the essence of,
of,
of gay identity,
sort of pushing those boundaries in
experimentation and transgender people
who have kind of fallen into this
authoritarian mode,
hate that kind of stuff.
It's not just,
it's not just about that,
it's not,
it's about our community fracturing if
you'd like,
but it's also that we see some of the
serious consequences to these
infringements on,
on culture because of course politics is
downstream from culture and what becomes
not unacceptable.
Sans Politics becomes unacceptable to
the.
So what becomes unacceptable in culture
becomes an and politics,
right?
Um,
and we recognize and we see the warning
signs.
So we're sort of the canary in the coal
mine.
Yes.
I think that's true.
I think gamers did this too,
you know,
I think gamers engaged very,
very similarly because gamers are
marginalized people in many cases.
I'm just proportionately ethnic
minority,
just fortunately gay,
disproportionately transgender in my
experience.
Often marginalized personalities are
often people who are retreating into
video games maybe because they have
great social skills,
often very bright,
sort of brilliant kind of autistic,
you know,
methodical.
I'm very male,
brilliant minds and very funny,
but sometimes don't have those social
skills.
And in that way they're quite similar to
gates because they had to occupy a
fairly unique position in the social
hierarchy of society and I think gamers
did in their own industry what gay
people ought to be doing in public life,
which is precisely that being a canary
in the coal mine and saying,
for example,
that the sort of nannying hectoring
language policing that's happening in
progressive media today is a problem as
a problem.
Because,
I mean,
this is the first signs are the policing
of gay sexuality.
There's a piece in,
in the daily beast I think that said
that,
um,
men who express a racial preference on
their grindr profile are racist now.
It's obviously an absurd thing to say
it's completely stupid and it was some
idiot middle class white woman,
um,
who decided that she was going to police
gay sexuality today just as well,
you know,
just as we were getting to a position of
tolerance,
suddenly there's someone coming up
coming over the horizon to police gay
sexuality.
It's happening for two reasons.
One,
I'm gay.
Men have high status in society.
They become very molly cold,
very celebrated in the media.
So they've sort of acquired a kind of
privilege and when the left,
the left is constantly engaged in the
business of ranking people according to
their oppression rating.
And Gay men don't school very well in
those games because,
you know,
we looked,
we looked good and we have money and
we're know we're,
we've basically become another kind of
white man.
Right.
So you would say that basically the
progressives,
or as I'm now calling them the
regressives basically you're done with
the gays.
Yes.
Yes,
that's exactly the world game sense.
They were like,
we're going to,
we're all for it done with you now
with,
you know,
they've got your gay marriage and now
you are going to find increasingly that
they come off to you and they're going
to come after you because you're being
too racially insensitive.
They're gonna come after you because you
use the wrong pronouns.
They're going to come after you absurdly
and brilliantly for massage one.
Um,
you know,
I mean people,
people make arguments to me sometimes
and they say,
and it's not as credible in your case,
but I can understand how we construct
the argument as bonkers as is.
And they make arguments that basically
boiled down to your sacrum.
Associates do,
you went gay,
um,
you know,
sort of,
you hate,
you hate women so much.
I can tell why you while you sleep with
men now happens to be that.
I do think there's a large element of
choice in my sexual orientation,
although that goes entirely against a
progressive consensus.
We'll do a whole thing on that in
another show,
but it's an extraordinary thing that
they now coming off to gay people for
being misogynistic,
for being racist or sorts.
Your no longer of any use to your own
site,
right?
They have used you and they have a
wedding ring on your finger.
They have,
they have domesticated view like they
would a dog like you did your dog.
They have put you in a.
They have,
they have made sure you got the right
politics that you say the right things
in public.
They have domesticated and delineated.
You know,
I'm the sort of useful liberal gay
idiots and put them all in little
ghettos in cities like the Castro and
West Hollywood.
And now you are the product and the um,
and the chattel of the,
of the liberal.
So I know both into you don't mean me
specific.
Now I do know they know I do many news,
but you know that I stand for into all
this.
But you know,
I stand again.
So it a sort of gay marriage as a way of
controlling gate.
Right?
But I suspect that along the way,
if you met the right person,
you would want to marry that person for
all the romance.
No,
I might move them into the west wing,
but I wouldn't marry them.
Okay.
So we do have to wrap up here and the
way we could have done three hours here
and we're.
We'll do this again for sure.
At this point.
I want to get to this,
this piece that has been the throughline
to everything we've been discussing
here,
this,
this authoritarian,
left this,
this regressive piece where there have
no problem relentless.
Look,
I could use the example of the gay
rights groups here in America,
you know,
glad or the HRC who will relent,
who will attack the pizza makers
relentlessly.
But we'll say nothing when gays are
thrown off the roof in Iran.
In Iran,
right?
Yeah.
Kind of
gay speak out.
You know,
I'm the only guy there is.
There is a sort of person in America
today.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but there's this sort of person in
America today who is a homosexual
discrimination against it's gay
conservatives.
It was much more difficult to admit
you're a gay conservative then you just
met,
you're gay,
you get slaps on the back,
you get applause.
You get,
Oh whoa.
Is Me Brave?
You know,
all of the sick,
all of the social signaling about being
homosexual is positive with one.
If you're a conservative other gays,
the gay establishment and brainstorm
notice wrote an amazing essay about this
in out magazine.
It's called something like in the rain
and the magical gail that everybody
should read.
It explains how the gay establishment,
which is basically now done with gays
and it's sort of a self perpetuating a
set of institutions to,
to push leftist socialist principles.
Got nothing to do with gay rights
anymore.
Um,
we'll treat you as what you would call
an uncle Tom in race terms.
Um,
you know,
I have never in my career as a
purposeful provocateur.
I don't play the victim on twitter or in
my columns because,
you know,
I think you should,
if you should take as well as you gave
them a rule,
all gay people on quite early in life.
Um,
but you think that one thing
that's shifting,
yeah,
it's a really long quietly.
Uh,
no,
it's,
you know,
I think you should be able to take it as
given.
And I never played the victim,
but I've never had so much really
poisonous vitriolic nastiness as from
other gays who think that my politics
are wrong.
It's horrible.
What did the ultimate success here?
But you know,
I've been arguing for a while now that
by gay marriage being legal now in
America,
in the,
in the longterm,
you actually help the Republicans
because this was such an idiotic issue
for so many people have to vote us,
is the idea that I had to vote on it.
Not that,
not that it was the deciding factor,
but it was,
I had to vote on whether I could get
married.
It's a fucking nonsensical and,
and painful and pathetic way to vote.
So I actually think ultimately this may
turn into a net win for the Republicans
because
I'm not sure that's the case now.
I've written about this,
and I call it minority,
was the way in which,
you know,
if the last 10 years was about setting
men and women against each other,
the next 10 years about all sorts of
other minorities.
I mean,
when the Hispanic population in the US
who are not encumbered by the guilt of
slavery become the,
the demographic majority,
you're going to see some pretty brutal
policing in places like Ferguson.
Um,
you know,
because they don't have the same kind of
white middle class guilt about,
uh,
about,
you know,
black lives matter.
They weren't,
you know,
Hispanic mayors in barely a few
generations.
I'm not going to be paying multimillion
dollar settlements to black families.
They're gonna be sending police in with
guns.
Um,
you know,
it's,
there's all sorts of horrible things on
the horizon and it's driven by the
identity politics of the left,
which are crumbling but not fast enough.
My serious point about all of this is
that cultural libertarianism or should I
keep banging on about,
which I think is what we've sort of what
we've been talking about,
which is a word that I'm glad is
catching on with people.
Can we just do it?
I know you named a few of them before,
but if from the article that I saw on
Breitbart,
I know that it was a brilliant article.
We'll link to it.
It wasn't like either way,
but.
But can we just name a couple of these
people?
I know you named a few,
but Bill Maher was included.
Chris rock is in there even though he
does rely a lot on his,
on his blackness as a source of his
comedy.
He noted that he is somebody,
for example,
who's spoken up about the political
correctness or colleges and college
campuses and says you won't perform for
students anymore because they're too
touchy.
I think he understands this.
I think Eli Roth,
the,
uh,
the horror director,
Adam Baldwin,
who's a sort of a fancy actor and um,
he said,
I'm not with the Gamergate stuff.
And then you've got the way these things
normally work because you've got sort of
vanguard of hell races like me and Katie
Hopkins in the UK and Coulter perhaps
here,
um,
now that all those,
those three happened to be right wing.
But I don't think it's,
I don't think you can play well that
thing you can place people in the
political spectrum.
And that's why I wanted you to mention
some of the names because what I liked
about the article was that these people
were from all over.
I think the hell raisers tends to be a
conservative today simply because the
establishment is liberal.
Right?
And I think that's why then a further
behind that you've got the more
politically ambiguous figures like
Christina Hoff summers at the American
Enterprise Institute or Cathy young
feminist journalist,
um,
who aren't so easy to place politically.
Kathy's definitely a liberal,
I think Christina is.
Christina is a registered Democrat,
in fact,
um,
you know,
but who nonetheless recognize the
excesses and they sort of in the wake of
the chaos created by the hell raisers
that people like me kind of winding
people up and being,
you know,
sort of viciously teasing people I
consider to be dangerous and damaging
and whatever.
Leave half of it.
But you're throwing bombs.
No,
no,
no.
I believe all of it.
I believe all of it,
but I'm perfectly happy to accept that I
will say at the most productive way
possible.
Um,
because I think the only responsible,
the only appropriate response to outrage
culture is to be outrageous.
You know,
if you're going to tell me that I can't
make jokes about,
about skin color,
I will come back at you,
you know,
with,
with 10 poems about me being obsessed
with black penises or whatever.
You know,
for the record,
you brought a six foot six black porn
star.
I hired,
I hired a black porn star just because
it would annoy the right people to be my
bodyguard because I get.
But I get death and bomb threats
everywhere I go.
And I didn't make a big song and dance
about accept to laugh at how stupid it
is when I didn't believe any feminist
bomb threats ever going to be credible.
They're kind of in Tyler and shoelaces
together,
let alone wire a detonator.
I'm not worried about getting blown up
by feminists.
Um,
what I,
uh,
am worried about is the chilling effect
that they have on free speech.
And just get back to the point.
Yeah,
I'm gay people,
I think,
and I think this is something in which
you and I are united,
uh,
having privileged access if you'd like
to,
you know,
the limits of acceptable speech and
discourse.
There's that great,
that great drag Queen Joke,
you know,
which I love from,
uh,
from Britain,
which always gets shocks and a national
newspaper wouldn't let me publish,
which was,
um,
she comes on stage and she says,
you're like my new hair.
It's called the Whitney black and died
in the bath.
And we will get,
sort of horrified.
But yeah,
it gave,
gave people live and love though,
you know,
that sort of stuff.
And we see before everybody else,
you know,
what the serious consequences of this
sort of chilling effect on free speech
can be and those consequences are,
there's,
you know,
the sum total of human human knowledge
and whatever,
you know,
starting to be caught off.
Js mill classical liberal is
unconscionable to modern feminism.
They don't believe some of the central
tenants of know on which British society
was built.
This is dangerous stuff.
It's dangerous stuff because of what's
happening in universities too.
I mean,
just look at the sorts of,
you know,
look at the,
the feminists hegemony,
you know,
women's studies departments that,
that run rampant on campuses.
Yale,
I don't know if this,
I hope
this is true and I'm not,
I'm misremembering this,
but I saw something,
you know,
Deray Mckesson,
the black lives matter.
This guy is teaching a course at Yale
and defensive looting,
you know,
all this kind of stuff.
This is a weird,
crazy.
So tweet about that.
I don't know if it's real,
we'll see.
But the women's studies suffered,
you know,
many decent universities is scary.
It's denying human knowledge is making
people.
And been this stuff makes it to
government policy regarding match.
You're not just talking about women's
studies though,
because this is coming from all over the
place,
like Berkeley Protesting Bill Maher
coming as a progressive ISM.
Generally.
I have a,
I've just seen,
I'm supposed to speak at USC tomorrow
night and I've just seen,
um,
you know,
this horrendous blog post from somebody
who says that I'm a sort of misogynistic
hate speech much.
And because I made a joke about,
I didn't know what it was.
It's probably some joke like,
you know,
feminist barbies just come out when you
pull the cord.
It says math is hard.
Let's lie about rape.
Um,
you know,
some,
some joke like that,
you know,
and they.
And they picked me out some sort of
misogynistic worth their words.
People.
I think that the takeaway and that
that's really where I sort of wanted to
end this with you because yeah,
we can.
Everything I've tried to do with this
show so far is show that you can
disagree with people and we can,
we can go back and argue the tenants of
feminism or whether I think you're right
or wrong about men being oppressed or,
or,
or the,
the gay marriage thing,
all those things,
uh,
but,
but allow the conversation to happen and
I think that's what's happening and
that's what the cultural libertarians
they were talking about are trying to
do.
We're trying to have the conversation.
So I appreciate you coming in and I want
to thank my guest,
Milo Yiannopoulos were dropping by.
You can check out his work
over@Breitbart.com.
Follow them on twitter.
It's at Nero.
I,
by the way,
make sure to tag me in all the hate
tweets because I know there's going to
be a lot of them.
It's at Rubin report and we'll do this
again next.